bien monsieur les présidents chers
courant porteurs chers collègues un
introduction de notre réunion je voulais
tout d'abord saluer la présence dans les
tribunes de cette salle d'une délégation
de la Chambre des conseillers du Maroc
qui est ici composé du président de sa
commission des finances de plusieurs de
ses services présidents et de ses et de
plusieurs conseillers
[Applaudissements]
je les remercie de l'intérêt qu'il porte
un autre travaux et vous le croirez ou
non dans les sujets que nous avons
évoqué nous avons évoqué les questions
de financement des collectivités locales
et fuguez vous que au Maroc aussi il y a
des sujets qui se posent voilà donc ça
nous rapproche sur ces premières
questions et nous y travaillerons dans
les mois qui viennent
nous nous réunissons donc ce matin une
deuxième fois
au sujet de l'enquête réalisée par la
Cour des comptes à notre demande sur le
fondement de l'article 58 2 de la LOLF
sur les scénarios de financement des
collectivités
territoriales le rapport de la Cour des
comptes nous avait été présenté par son
premier président en octobre dernier ce
qui avait constitué un éclairage utile
dans la perspective de l'examen des
textes budgétaires de l'automne la
méthodologie retenue convenue avec la
cour est fondée sur la présentation de
scénario dit polaire
de financement des collectivités
territoriales
cette méthode elle le mérite de poser
sereinement l'ensemble des enjeux qui se
présentent à nous et surtout de fournir
une grille d'analyse précieuse dans la
perspective de futurs évolutions du
panier de ressources des collectivités
c'est une étape nécessaire si nous
voulons enfin parvenir à réformer un
système dont nous constatons chaque jour
tous il y a pas de difficulté les
limites et bien entendu nous en
constatons les limites mais nous sommes
incapables collectivement de dégager un
consensus sur les solutions à apporter
alors comme je suis un optimiste
convaincu je doute pas que cette matinée
sera utile du point de vue de la
recherche du consensus
et en tout cas ce serait bien
ce serait bien dans ce travail que nous
avons souhaité pour poser quelque chose
sur la table
en tant que parlementaire si nous
pouvions éviter d'être à fond pour la
réforme
j'ai un doute
ou sur le scénario parce qu'il y a pas
de réformes en soi
proposer
ou que l'on soit totalement contre par
principe donc je suis sûr que chacun
aura vocation à bien discerner ce qui
pourrait être les thèmes sur lesquels on
pourrait avancer des thèmes qui posent
des problèmes j'allais dire presque de
ligne rouge sur tel ou tel sujet
le caractère systémique des scénarios de
réforme qui sont présentés qui n'avaient
pas vocation à trouver une traduction
immédiate bien entendu justifie que nous
remettions désormais à tête reposée
l'ouvrage sur le métier
il ne s'agit pas bien entendu
aujourd'hui de présenter à nouveau les
travaux de la cour la synthèse de ces
travaux et les recommandations vous
aurez été distribués pour les collègues
de la commission des finances ont déjà
été débattus mais il n'était apparu
indispensable d'inviter les
représentants des différentes strates de
collectivités territoriales à nous faire
part publiquement de leur réaction et je
remercie encore une fois la cour de
cette rendue à nouveau disponible pour
participer à nos échanges nous aurons
d'ailleurs
l'audition la semaine prochaine de
région de France et de l'assemblée du
département de France nous n'avons pas
souhaité pour de raisons de
simplification et de lecture mettre
toutes les collectivités toutes les
strates de collectivité ensemble pour
recueillir vos observations donc ce
matin il est consacré aux observations
du bloc communal
et nous avons donc le plaisir
d'accueillir outre le président de la
première chambre Christian Charpy de
madame le rapporteur qui l'accompagne
bien entendu que je remercie également
Pierre BRETON président de la commission
finance de l'Association des maires de
France et des présidents
d'intercommunalité la MF Denis Durand
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France
Sébastien Miossec qui est donc en visio
parce que il y a eu un petit souci de
transport c'est le problème de la
Bretagne quelquefois
et donc il n'a pas pu nous rejoindre ce
matin et en remplacement de Sébastien
Martin empêché
et puis bien sûr François repsomain je
dis bien sûr parce que François
recemment on le retrouve toujours avec
plaisir au Sénat une maison où il a
sévit dans le passé si je puis dire le
mot Séville bon
effectivement bien entendu
et qui est président de la commission
financière fiscalité de France urbaine
donc avant de donner la parole à notre
panel d'invité je vous rappelle
simplement que nous considérons que vous
avez été
reçu les documents que d'ailleurs vous
avez fait un retour directement auprès
de la Cour qui vous avez sollicité et
vos avis ont déjà une certaine façon été
pris en compte dans le rendu par la cour
avant de donner la parole un autre panel
d'invité et ce sera direct je vais céder
la parole à mes deux corps rapporteurs
Jean-François Husson et Charles Gonet
pour quelques minutes de rapports
complémentaires
merci monsieur le Président ce sera
effectivement très bref je m'associe
évidemment à vos souhaits de bienvenue
et surtout je remercie l'ensemble des
participants que ce soit au titre de la
Cour des comptes ou des associations
d'élus et où on retrouve je crois avec
plaisir notre ancien collègue je sais
pas si c'est x tout court ex futur la
vie publique étant tellement
source d'imprévus bon
peut-être juste quelques mots pour
dire que ce on souhaite effectivement
nourrir notre travail autour des
propositions qui sont formulées
notamment par la Cour des comptes sur
la question d'un nouvel impôts
résidentiel chacun a bien compris qu'on
a des pour les collectivités
dont certains continuent de dire je
parle là plutôt de ce que j'entends de
la part du gouvernement quelles sont
dans une bonne situation financière on a
même l'impression que tout va bien j'ai
encore lu quelques articles à ce sujet
hier
ce qui en tous les cas
ressort c'est la question de l'autonomie
financière et la question des ressources
fiscales des collectivités voilà il y a
des propositions dans la commande que
nous avions
adressé à la cour nous avons
effectivement souhaité avoir des
propositions pour nourrir le débat je
pense que ça arrive parfaitement
un bon moment et donc je souhaite que
les uns et les autres puissent exprimer
leur
parc d'accord de désaccord les questions
de telle manière que avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes et avec nos collègues
nous puissions pour suivre
ces travaux ça n'est pas fini le
président Claude Raynal vient de
rappeler dans quel contexte nous nous
inscrivions
oui merci monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Présidents ce
rapporteur général et Mesdames et
Messieurs
je voudrais bien sûr
apporter moi aussi mais remerciements
à chacun des chacune des personnes qui
qui sont présentes avec nous en ce qui
me concerne François Rebsamen je c'est
un voisin donc je le vois encore plus
souvent que vous bien
je souhaiterais en ce qui me concerne
peut-être ajouter un élément aux
analyses qui qui nous sont chers et qui
me qui me préoccupent
c'est
l'un des constats qui a été fait par la
Cour et le fait qu'il faudrait
certainement s'intéresser aussi en
dehors des articulations de nos
ressources à une nouvelle gouvernance
des finances publiques et je pense que
même si le rapport ne développe pas de
manière
disons complètes ce sujet je pense qu'il
serait important que vous nous donniez
votre avis sur cet aspect car un moment
où à la fois nous devons
discuter de la partition entre la part
d'un d'impôt d'État qui peut revenir qui
doit rester à l'état et de la part qui
tu dois aller au collectivités locales
puisque on est de plus en plus même si
pour le bloc communal c'est un peu moins
vrai avec je veux dire des impôts
nationaux cette première répartition est
importante et de plus nous voyons aussi
que la plupart du temps le gouvernement
s'adresse
à chacune des parties pour discuter un
peu de ce qu'il va lui attribuer et nous
sommes beaucoup pas pensé et moi en
particulier qu'il serait temps qu'il y
ait quand même une organisation de tout
cela dans un cadre institutionnel un peu
plus sérieux et comme chacun aussi a
constaté l'obsolescence de notre système
peut-être que ça permettrait aussi à des
réformes d'avancer un peu plus vite je
serai nous serons assez à intéresser par
votre avis sur sur cette question merci
merci Charles
[Musique]
nous je vous propose tout de suite de
bien vouloir
nous allons passer tout de suite donc à
vos avis à vous propositions à vos
remarques
en notant encore une fois que ça fait
quelques 30 ans maintenant que je
m'intéresse à la question
que le nombre de fois où on a constaté
les difficultés considérables le nombre
de fois où on a fait des espèces de
scotch dans tous les sens pour essayer
de trouver des équilibres c'est aussi
heureux de quoi écrire trois tomes que
tout le monde est d'accord pour que ça
bouge et que personne n'est d'accord sur
quoi que ce soit je le fais simple je
excusez-moi
mais je le fais simple et et je dis
pourquoi le Parlement finalement
s'autorise à essayer de pousser un peu
les feux pour que pourquoi on sorte et
qu'on essaye d'arriver à quelque chose
qui dans des années
futures soit de meilleures de meilleure
qualité et sur lesquels on puisse se
retrouver les uns les autres alors je
vais donner la parole tout de suite à
François epsonin alors
n'y voyez pas
l'idée de donner à fond urbaine un
premier rôle mais reconnaissez à
François recemel cette qualité
d'avoir nous avoir fait savoir qu'il
devait repartir rapidement et ce qui lui
permet de parler en premier si vous le
voulez bien voilà toute la biloté du
maire de Dijon
François tu as la parole
je voudrais merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
remercier également Jean-François Husson
Charles Guénet de cette réunion
organisée par la commission des finances
du Sénat remercier bien sûr Christian
Charpy et à travers lui la rapporteur
madame la rapporteur et bien sûr le
travail qui a été effectué par la Cour
des comptes et puis vous dire que la
démarche que vous avez entamée engagé et
d'autant plus intéressantes qu'elle est
elle n'est pas sur le court terme de la
loi de finances qui vient d'être adoptée
mais
elle est sur une perspective un peu
stratégique de de moyen terme qui permet
ou qui doit permettre d'avoir des
réflexions avec plusieurs scénarios qui
permettront après d'avancer donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
non seulement pertinent mais également
tout à fait
stimulant alors évidemment
le président et madame le rapporteur
mais je voudrais à travers ça dire
combien le rapport de la Cour des
comptes a été intéressant François
urbaine il y a participé par ces
réponses des éléments ont été apportés
certains d'ailleurs ont été retenus et
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de propositions qui étaient tout
à fait tout à la fois nouvelle
un peu je cherche les mots mais
disruptifs par rapport à ce qu'on
connaît je vais prendre un seul exemple
mais il me tient à cœur et je vous en
donnerai un exemple précis il s'agit des
DMTO j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
enfin d'en dire un mot avec
comment dire rapidement avec un exemple
très concret pour que on reste dans les
choses claires bien sûr pour autant on
n'est pas en partage pas les 100% des
propositions qui sont faites mais
personne ici ne va pas dire cela mais
vraiment c'est tout à fait un travail
tout à fait intéressant qui a été mené
et au moins je pense
peut-être avancer sur un premier
consensus que vous envisagiez monsieur
le Président rénal en disant que la
nécessité de disposer pour le bloc
communal on va dire pour le bloc
communal de recettes
territorialisée
devrait je crois nous rassembler pour le
moins avec bien sûr d'autre part mais ça
ça fait tellement d'années qu'on le
répète la nécessité bien sûr d'une
remise en cause profonde des relations
financières entre l'État et les
collectivités moi je n'ai pas votre
expérience
j'ai juste j'étais juste jeune
conseiller de Pierre Jacques pour les
premières lois de décentralisation donc
je me rappelle de cette mise en oeuvre
et je me dis 40 ans plus tard on va dire
les choses comme ça 40 ans plus tard
bien des sujets qui avait été lancé sont
toujours là et n'ont pas trouvé de
réponse et on peut dire que de ce côté
là
l'accumulation de des réformes des
réformes réforme réformes fiscales qui
ont été
élaborés
certaine voter bien évidemment
ont toujours été du seul point de vue de
l'État qui qui considère et qui continue
de de considérer par essence les
collectivités locales territoriales
comme des collectivités dépensières et
c'est l'image que en ont nous nos amis
de Bercy et donc à travers cela en
permanence
on ne se pose jamais la question ou peu
au niveau de l'état des
des allocataires de la peau locale dire
les choses plus simplement que sont les
collectivités et tout ça amener à une
architecture de des ressources qui sont
pour certaines totalement des
responsabilisés on peut dire des choses
comme ça et bien sûr à travers cette des
responsabilisation il y a une perte je
le crois je le considère mais je parle
au nom de François urbaine des des
comment dire de l'efficacité de l'action
locale évidemment des
responsabilisations égales perte
d'efficacité de l'action publique locale
alors je veux pas citer d'exemple mais
j'en prends que deux rapides mais vous
les connaissez aussi bien que moi la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences principales et puis ce
combat que j'ai mené également comme
rapporteur d'une commission qu'on
m'avait confié que le gouvernement avait
confié sur
la construction de logements sociaux où
il a fallu se battre et se battre pour
obtenir des compensations au fil du
temps pour arriver à quelque chose d'à
peu près raisonnable et donc le rapport
de la Cour met en avant le renforcement
de la fiscalité locale qui apparaît la
plus adaptée au bloc communal et
je pense que ça se justifie là encore ça
devrait être un point de consensus
puisque la loi a donné la compétence
générale aux communes en l'occurrence ce
qui permet normalement de renforcer le
lien avec le territoire bon normalement
cette renforcement de l'autonomie
fiscale doit si elle arrive
ce concrétiser par un renforcement
également de l'efficacité je le crois
des de la solidarité territoriale et de
péréquation donc je sais le Sénat a été
longtemps porteur
donc on peut dire que il n'est pas
acceptable je le crois aujourd'hui que
les finances la gouvernance des finances
locales demeurent aussi archaïque et
soit placé sous le signe permanent
évoquais tout à l'heure de la défiance
on va dire dans le fonctionnement tout
ça vient de de la verticalité bien
évidemment des relations entre l'État et
les collectivités
l'absence de concertation
pas forcément d'ailleurs sur tel ou tel
moment de la vie mais sur la durée on
peut dire l'absence de concertation sur
la durée c'est un obstacle je crois
l'installation d'une gouvernance
efficace est responsable des finances
locales donc je dirais qu'il vaut mieux
il faut mieux associer les collectivités
à la préparation des lois de finances
cette évoqué dans dans le rapport et je
crois que ça devrait devenir une
priorité
pour l'État
il y a eu plusieurs propositions qui ont
été faites au fil du temps sur ce sujet
sous la forme de loi de finances
spécifiques aux collectivités locales et
autres peut-être à jour tout cela
viendra en tous les cas je pense que on
ne peut pas accepter que les
collectivités par exemple je prends un
exemple découvre au détour d'un 49-3 le
report de deux ans d'un engagement de la
révision des valeurs locatives qui
avaient été pris
devant tout le monde donc je ne citerai
pas d'autres 49-3 qui ont
mis en place momentanément ça a été
retourné mais des dispositions qui
n'étaient pas prévues du tout par le
gouvernement lui-même en fait qu'il
n'avait pas lui-même a compris dans tous
les sens on peut associer je crois à ce
moment-là des propositions
opérationnelles
la cour en a formulé la cour propose de
mettre en place une autorité par exemple
une autorité indépendante
qui émettrai un avis sur les projets de
loi relatifs tout ça dans
l'esprit de veiller on va dire de
veiller au respect des principes
d'équilibre de compensation des
transferts de compétences et des
suppressions de fiscalité et aussi de
réduction bien sûr des inégalités entre
les collectivités
en faisant cette proposition
j'en parlais avec Franck caisse je
remercie pour tout le travail qui fait
attention ben d'ailleurs ici devant tout
le monde
en disant cela en même temps on écarte
un peu facilement quand même le CFL qui
on ne peut pas comme ça balayer d'un
revers de main peut-être réfléchir aussi
à un rôle renforcé différents pour pour
le CFL qui est une émanation une
représentation des collectivités locales
et donc comment lui donner plus de le
responsabilité autoritaire indépendante
CFL renforcée
les options sont devant nous je veux
dire en toute état de cause il faut
trouver des solutions pour
opérationnelles voilà mais permet
permettez-moi simplement je vous
interrompre une seconde la proposition
de la cour justement mentionne les deux
possibilités est-ce que vous avez un
avis en tant qu'association sur moi ou
autorité juste pour
la vie personnelle c'est pas forcément
je consulte pas tous les collègues de
France urbaine ni les autres mères moi
je crains toujours les autorités
indépendantes donc je préfère que ce
soit des émanations des collectivités
locales à titre personnel quand je dis
cela mais tout en sachant que tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui même s'il
fonctionne bien sous la haute autorité
d'André Le Niel bien sûr
ce comité des finances locales bon il
faut peut-être pas qu'il se perdent dans
des analyses de décret qui sont souvent
subalternes et plutôt se concentrer sur
l'essentiel
qui sont les lois de finances je le
crois tout à l'heure j'ai parlé parce
que ça a été évoqué de
ddmto et dans le rapport l'idée de faire
du DMTO ddmto
un impôt national tel que c'est évoqué
et est une une proposition à examiner
qu'on peut estimer pertinente parce que
alors pour deux raisons ou trois raisons
la première c'est que on a besoin de
visibilité les collectivités ont besoin
de visibilité sur des recettes qui sont
très aléatoires on va dire la vérité et
qui sont très différentes d'un
territoire à un autre et donc
mais quand même et là-dessus on pourrait
se retrouver c'est quand même l'action
communale ou intercommunale qui qui est
le moteur de la dynamique des DMTO pour
l'essentiel pour l'essentiel vu qu'ils
je suis aussi d'un territoire viticole
je sais qu'il n'y a pas que cette action
là mais
l'essentiel vient de l'action communale
intercommunale et je trouve
particulièrement curieux mais il y a
d'autres choses curieuses mais ça sera
pour votre prochaine audition monsieur
les présidents vice-président avec le
département qui lui engrange les DMTO
sur le travail communal je vais prendre
un exemple si vous le permettez très
concret
il se trouve que nous avons un grand
centre commercial dans la ville de Dijon
que
Charles gaine et connaît centre la
Toison d'Or qui fonctionne voilà il y en
a deux trois quatre comme ça en France
et donc il a été vendu il a été vendu
pour le modeste prix de 400 millions
d'euros CD et je dois dire que ce centre
il a été installé par mon prédécesseur
et et conforté par moi-même en tant que
mère bien sûr et j'ai eu des recours du
département contre ce centre et ça m'a
quand même trouver j'ai trouvé
particulièrement
curieux pour ne pas dire un adjectif
plus fort que ça que le département
touche plus de 20 millions d'euros de
DMTO plus de 20 millions d'euros de DMTO
et que la ville n'en touche que 4,5
millions alors que c'est vraiment un
projet communal qui a vu le jour au fil
du temps bon je prends cet exemple mais
il y a d'autres curiosités dans la vie
locale le fait que des collectivités
sans compétences continuent de toucher
un impôt économique enfin je pourrais en
dénumérer plein vous voyez ce que je
veux dire donc il faut clarifier à un
moment et je pense que le travail que
vous faites permettra de le faire la la
relation pour éviter une relation de
dépendance
ou de
comment dire de maîtrise d'une
collectivité sur une autre les relations
entre le bloc communal au sens large et
les départements c'est un avis qui
n'engage que moi mais ça va ça va venir
et donc
parmi les propositions que nous avons
porté au cours de la de la campagne la
campagne présidentielle on a souhaité
que
soit revu mais ça a été évidemment
énoncé dans le rapport que soit revu ces
dotations de compensation qui qui ne
sont qu'une manière d'appauvrir un peu
plus les collectivités dans la relation
puisque c'est dotations de compensation
constitue ce que nous appelons vous
aussi d'ailleurs une fiscalité morte qui
non seulement n'évolue pas comme auréole
évolué
ces impôts ou ces taxes quand ils
étaient en place mais qui en plus sont
rognés après
année par des décisions gouvernementales
qui peuvent être prises lors des
commissions de la loi de finance donc
l'idée de les remplacer par une fraction
de de TVA de taxe sur la valeur ajoutée
permettrait je crois de mettre un terme
à cela et puis de redonner une dynamique
parce que le principe quand même c'est
d'avoir cette dynamique qui soit au
service de la réduction des inégalités
territoriales parce que elles ne sont
pas toutes sur le même niveau en terme
de capacité d'action c'est vrai et si on
veut vraiment plus que dans les mots
agir avoir des politiques de transition
écologique qui soit conduite par les
collectivités donc
j'aborderai je vais avancer parce que je
ne veux pas être trop long je vois que
je suis un peu long j'avance vite un
diagnostic aussi quand même qu'il faut
avoir relatif aux subventions
d'investissement bon les appels à projet
ça suffit mais
c'est très curieux c'est pratique qui
font que finalement on a redonné du
pouvoir à l'État central à travers les
préfets qui ont des politiques
différentes suivant les territoires et
donc les investissements des
collectivités peuvent y accéder suivant
l'interprétation qu'on fera les préfets
que ce soit dans le cadre de la des cils
que ce soit dans le cadre de la drtr la
DTR nous avons donc
DETR pardon nous avons donc des
positions qui sont très différentes très
différentes parce que il y a pas de
ligne directrice et c'est pas ce que je
vois du tout en ce moment la ligne
directrice enfin parce que j'ai dit que
j'avançais
on a aussi des points de désaccord sur
ce rapport que je voudrais évoquer
rapidement très rapidement
moi je suis contre la banalisation du
FCTVA parce que je veux pas qu'on le
transforme en une
subvention d'investissement voilà pour
simplifier et c'est vrai que ça a été je
remercie le travail qui a été fait par
la Cour parce que ça figurait dans le
premier rapport je l'ai pas retrouvé
dans le deuxième donc
vous avez tenu compte je pense des
remarques et puis dire aussi
à ces éminents responsables que les
petites taxes les petites taxes ne sont
pas des impôts de rendement
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire je
vais prendre un exemple je terminerai
par là la taxe locale sur la publicité
la TLPE permet d'agir concrètement par
de la somme collectée elle permet d'agir
et d'or des politiques et donc
la possibilité de supprimer des grandes
affiches des quatre par trois comme je
viens de le faire une certaine nombre de
communes d'autres l'avaient fait bien
longtemps d'ailleurs
les grands mâts d'annoncent
publicitaires qui qui sont retirés parce
que ils coûtent cher à aux entreprises
concernées je vais prendre l'exemple
d'Ikea Charles quand tu venais à Dijon
tu voyais à 10 km tu voyais le grand
oui je l'ai cité c'est trop tard je m'en
excuse mais il est connu il est jaune et
bleu je vais dire c'est tout ce que je
veux dire il est jaune et bleu donc il
faut il faut pas penser que ça soit des
des impôts à négliger ces petites taxes
pour les collectivités et elle leur
permet d'orienter leur politique au plus
près de nos concitoyens merci j'en ai
terminé monsieur le Président et je vous
remercie de l'écoute et je m'excuse
d'avoir été un peu long merci
François et semaine
donc nous allons poursuivre peut-être
avec dans l'ordre je proposerai à Pierre
breton d'intervenir maintenant pour le
MF à Denis Durand en suivant et nous
terminerons avec notre ami en visio pour
intercommunalité de France pour donner
l'ordre
pierre Breteau alors vous avez à peu
près le même temps voir un petit peu
moins quoi je l'ai pas mesuré mais
président donc moi je l'ai fait
en tout cas merci monsieur le Président
de nours de recevoir messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs c'est
merci de nous donner l'occasion monsieur
le Président de d'échanger aussi
oralement sur les propositions que vous
formez le président de la commission
vous appeliez de vos vœux que nous
puissions identifier des points de
consensus alors je ne résiste pas à
démarrer par là peut-être pour dériver
progressivement
sur les points qui peuvent faire un peu
moins consensus mais vous savez comme
Sébastien je viens de Bretagne les vents
ils sont parfois forts et en attendant
parfois à dériver sur les points de
consensus d'abord peut-être
dire qu'on partage globalement l'analyse
qui a été faite par la Cour sur le
niveau de dépenses locales sur son
évolution n'insiste quand même sur les
évolutions qui ont qui sont corolle qui
sont corollaires l'évolution de la
dépense d'une dépense c'est pas une
valeur absolue c'est qu'en général on
règle générale a été en face de
compétences et qui a eu toute une série
de transferts de compétences ou de
modification structurelle l'organisation
qui ont conduites à l'évolution de ses
dépenses je voudrais m'attarder sur
quelques quelques points pour lequel
nous avons des constats partagés
le premier il est essentiel il est lié à
l'augmentation des ratios d'autonomie
financière
et
parallèlement de la diminution des
ratios d'autonomie fiscale et c'est bien
là tout un point assez clé alors
évidemment les ratiosotomie de
financières c'est un problème de
dénominateur
dès lors que la DGF est réduite
drastiquement ça augmente l'autonomie
financière mais le fond du sujet et qui
conduit un certain nombre de
propositions et qui doit conduire notre
réflexion c'est la diminution de
l'autonomie fiscale
alors Françoise Flamel l'a dit tout à
l'heure on sait que ça peut être le
vieux rêve d'un certain nombre de
ministères de l'un d'entre eux en
particulier
je ne le cite pas de marque
mais pour autant
c'est un point assez essentiel dans la
construction même de la décentralisation
et de la façon de faire vivre une
République décentralisée et au-delà de
l'aspect assez technique de ce ratio
d'autonomie financière d'autonomie
fiscale ce que nous posons comme
question c'est la question qui est
politique qui est derrière la capacité
d'un élu local
du bloc communal Dans le cadre de notre
audition de ce matin mais globalement
des élus locaux en général de pouvoir
décider ou infléchir des politiques
publiques et d'appeler l'impôt
pour lequel ils ont été élus ils ont
mandat
pour pouvoir mettre en œuvre c'est
politique publique c'est un point
vraiment essentiel parfois on nous
oppose le modèle allemand
qui est effectivement un modèle pour
essentiel sous dotation mais je rappelle
que la chambre haute
de l'Allemagne ne joue pas du tout le
même rôle et on en reparlera tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs sur la question de la
visibilité des dépenses et de ce qui
pourrait être un cadrage des finances
publiques locales et donc pour nous un
point essentiel c'est de redonner une
forme d'autonomie fiscale
au collectivités territoriales en
général et au bloc communal en
particulier
le deuxième est
j'extrapole peut-être un petit peu les
propos de la cour mais enfin en tout cas
on partage l'analyse sur l'évolution de
ces ratios et je redis quelle était la
position mais elle est très connue de la
MF sur ce sur ce point
le deuxième point de consensus il est
extrêmement important c'est celui de la
visibilité
les collectivités du bloc communal ont
cette particularité de porter à la fois
les services publics du quotidien
et à la fin 70% des investissements
publics les écoles les routes les
réseaux d'eau et d'assainissement les
transports en commun etc etc
la plupart de ces investissements c'est
du temps long une école avant de la
rénover en totalité 25 30 ans un réseau
de transport
j'habite dans la métropole de Rennes un
réseau de transport lourd type métro les
galeries qui ont été creusées 100 ans
bien nous décidons quotidiennement
de politique de politique publique qui
se traduisent par des investissements
qui sont sur du temps long et dans le
même temps on apprend 4 jours 5 jours 6
jours 7 jours tous les ans tout
gouvernement confondu d'ailleurs
comment vont évoluer les finances le 2
janvier suivant
cette dissymétrie temporelle
pose un problème majeur
pose un problème majeur et donc la
question non pas de la prévisibilité
parce que malheureusement rien n'est
plus incertain que l'avenir mais en tout
cas la lisibilité
nous semble être un point clé et je
voudrais vraiment
dire que ce point qui qui a été repris
par la Cour est un point c'est le
deuxième point essentiel autonomie
fiscale et lisibilité j'ajouterai trois
paramètres qui devrait fonder notre
réflexion collective la lisibilité
parce que le système fiscal doit être
compréhensible par le contribuable c'est
un enjeu démocratique
la prévisibilité ou en tout cas qu'on
puisse anticiper ces évolutions et
troisième principe la responsabilité
l'AMF a eu l'occasion de le dire à de
très nombreuses reprises on ne peut pas
Satis se satisfaire d'un système dans
lequel celui qui décide ne finance pas
parce que il y a une forme de confusion
globale de qui est responsable de quoi
et donc une confusion sur le montant de
l'impôt et donc une confusion
démocratique donc au-delà de la question
financière la question de la
responsabilité est une question de mon
point de vue politique et financière
essentiel politique parce que chacun
porte la responsabilité d'infléchir
telle ou telle politique publique
mais financière aussi parce qu'on sait
du coup que dès lors que des compétences
sont transférées des normes nouvelles
seront imposées elles pourront faire
l'objet d'un financement par celui ou
celle qui l'a décidé la responsabilité
que j'invoque pour les collectivités
locales je la revendique aussi pour le
gouvernement
et donc effectivement ça pose la
question de pilotage des finances
publiques et vous savez que nous
appelons nos vœux à la fois une forme de
loi de programmation distincte du bloc
local de l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales du bloc communal
et à la fois une instance et je partage
totalement ce qu'a dit Françoise ça mène
j'ai la même méfiance que lui
des hautes autorités indépendantes dont
on ne sait finalement plus de qui elles
sont les manations et quelle est leur
indépendance réelle et je fais confiance
en revanche aux élus de la République et
je pense qu'une instance qui émane qui
émanerait de la République pour
s'assurer en fait de la qualité de la
construction financière entre dans la
relation entre les collectivités
territoriales et les genoux central me
semble être une instance nécessaire
alors ça peut être comme on l'a lui
récemment le CFL la fusion du CFL et du
cnen ce peut-être voilà en tout cas on
peut travailler
sur une instance qui l'émanation des
colliers locales et qui s'assure
de la ou ça peut être le Sénat bien sûr
absolument c'est dans la Constitution
absolument
je suis pas dans la proposition en tant
que telle je dis juste qu'il faut que
une instance indépendante et si elle est
parlementaire c'est encore mieux puisse
être garante de l'équilibre de la
relation financière dans la durée entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales
le troisième point bon ce sont des
points plus techniques la nécessité de
poursuivre la révision de la valeur
locative la suppression des frais
d'acier de recouvrement qui sont devenus
anachronique enfin un certain nombre de
points sur lesquels on pourra échanger
le cas échéant sur lequel je veux je
veux pas m'étendre trop longuement
et puis évidemment je voudrais évoquer
les propositions qui sont faites en
matière de de contenu de la réforme
fiscale alors vous comprenez à travers
les propos que j'ai tenues qu'on partage
pas forcément les propositions
qui qui ont pu être faites par la Cour
globalement pourquoi pour deux raisons
d'abord parce qu'elle repose globalement
sur un sous-jacent qui est un
sous-jacent de
recentralisation puis répartition
je peux prendre l'exemple que vient
d'être évoqué et je vais le poursuivre
par François hepsamène sur les DMTO
ni pas que la question des DMTO peut
poser problème
parce qu'il peut y avoir des impacts
importants il y a des sessions
spécifiques vous évoquiez session de
centre commercial j'ai dans ma commune
une session d'un énorme centre
hospitalier qui voilà bénéficie du coup
pour l'essentiel au département
d'Ille-et-Vilaine tant mieux pour lui
donc qu'il y ait une forme de travail
sur la question de la péréquation n'y
reviendra mais en tout cas le
sous-jacent il repose sur d'abord une
recentralisation et le cas échéant
par des répartitions c'est le cas de la
proposition sur les to si je l'ai bien
vous voyez d'abord nationalisation puis
ensuite répartition plutôt au bénéfice
du bloc communal on s'en réjouit et à la
fois je représente l'Association des
maires de France mais je ne peux pas me
désintéresser du sort des départements
et des régions c'était à peu près la
seule recette dynamique qui pouvait leur
rester donc il y a un sujet par ailleurs
sur les départements les régions mais
j'ai compris que vous aurez une audition
qui sera consacrée ils en reparleront
probablement
on peut le dire on peut on peut on peut
le penser on peut le penser
et donc
fondamentalement
nous aurions espéré que le rapport soit
encore plus disruptif
pour alors je partage par ailleurs ce
qui a été dit concernant le bloc
communal c'est à dire la nécessité de
territorialiser l'impôt et d'ailleurs on
le retrouve bien dans vos propositions
mais de le territorialiser en totalité
c'est à dire sur l'ensemble de ce qui
fait vivre le territoire
ce qui fait vivre le territoire c'est
les usagers les contribuables déjà je
les contribuables entreprises
l'action que nous menons elle est au
bénéfice des usagers de services publics
des habitants des contribuables des
entreprises qui vont vivre le territoire
et donc le financement de ces
compétences ne peut pas faire l'impasse
sur tel ou tel type de catégories de
bénéficiaires de l'action publique
locale
c'est tout d'ailleurs tout le débat
qu'on a eu sur la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est l'illustration c'est
tout le débat qu'on a eu sur la
suppression de la table d'habitation
c'est tout le débat qu'on a eu dans le
cadre récemment de la CVAE
et donc
l'AMF porte elle le portait dans le
cadre de la campagne présidentielle
dernière d'ailleurs précise
l'idée que
il doit y avoir un impôt clair et simple
pour les différents niveaux de
collectivité territoriale fusent
d'ailleurs sur une base qui soit la même
chose d'ailleurs sur une base qui soit
la même pour retrouver je relis au début
de mon propos pour le retrouver et de la
lisibilité et une forme d'autonomie
fiscale
le deuxième sujet qui nous semble
important
c'est la péréquation et la péréquation
qui repose
sur la fiscalité alors nous ne disons
pas qu'il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait une forme de péréquation
mais elle ne peut pas reposer que sur
des mécanismes de péréquation
horizontaux et fiscaux
sinon
d'ailleurs
on constate que font les présidents de
région que font les présidents de
départements une partie de leur action
de leurs moyens consiste à corriger les
inégalités territoriales
et donc on ne peut pas faire reposer
sur un même bloc de collectivité
l'ensemble
des paramètres de péréquation certes il
doit y avoir de la péréquation
horizontale mais il doit également y
avoir de la péréquation verticale la
péréquation horizontale corrige les
écarts de richesse en partie réduits
verticale garantie l'équité territoriale
et donc ça ne peut pas être l'un sans
l'autre c'est obligatoirement l'un et
l'autre or ces dernières années la
plupart des dispositifs péricoiteurs ont
porté
sur la péréquation horizontale pour une
raison extrêmement simple c'est que
l'ensemble des fonds des enveloppes
attribuées à la péréquation d'évoluer
plus et donc en réalité 100% de la
péréquation était portée par les
collectivités elle-même et les
collectivités de la même strate entre
elles du même bloc on va dire
ce qui nous semble être
un problème majeur
problème accru depuis quelques mois par
la
les nouvelles périodes d'inflation dans
laquelle nous entrons c'est à dire que
déjà en période flat sans inflation on a
un peu oublié de finalement le pilotage
en général en période d'inflation parce
que finalement ça date des inflations de
ce niveau
mais on ne peut pas avoir des dotations
de l'État qui sont figées
à la fois pour garantir la réforme du
système de dotation devenu obsolète à la
fois pour garantir de retrouver des
mécanismes de péréquation verticaux
sinon la contrepartie de ça ça veut dire
que les seuls dispositifs de péréquation
porteront sur la fiscalité dans le cadre
d'une péréquation horizontale et ce qui
en fait est une négation des politiques
d'équité territoriales que doit mener
par ailleurs l'État
merci vous avez à peu près je suis à peu
près équivalent oui très bien alors
écoutez je m'arrête là je répondrai aux
questions après volontiers merci
monsieur le Président
vous l'avez dit vous-même une série de
questions et donc l'occasion en
conclusion de reprendre les points les
points saillants Denis durant
pour les mères ruraux de France
le président mesdames messieurs merci de
d'avoir invité l'association des mers
ruraux pour pouvoir exprimer son point
de vue je représente Michel Fournier et
qui m'a demandé de le représenter
aujourd'hui
venant souvent au fond par rapport
de la Cour des comptes je partage nous
partageons globalement ce que vient de
dire notre collègue Pierre Breteau
mais je voudrais insister tout
particulièrement sur un certain nombre
de points
aujourd'hui notre pays connaît une
fracture territoriale énorme entre les
métropoles et je dirais le reste du pays
avec des conséquences
un calcul je veux dire la concentration
de la richesse
pose des problèmes la concentration des
populations pose des problèmes et la
désertification d'un autre côté en pose
beaucoup je veux dire une des missions
de l'État c'est de résorber cette
fracture territoriale
donc pour ça il faut aussi une
peréquation qui soit volontaire
je reviens à l'organisation
administrative de notre pays et date
pour l'essentiel de 1789 ou l'État
nation a eu toute son importance et on a
repris dans l'administration on a repris
on a créé la commune sur les bases des
anciennes paroisses et qui est devenu la
cellule de base de la République et un
échelon intermédiaire qui était le
département
création du département contre les
régions
contre la féodalité à l'époque des
diagonales et les départements ce grand
avantage et qui sont tous de même
dimension au niveau de la surface à part
ce qu'on a créé récemment sur la région
parisienne créée dans les années 60
donc c'est un outil essentiel pour
l'aménagement du territoire
donc aujourd'hui nos concitoyens se
retrouvent dans ces trois niveaux
d'administration
d'abord au niveau électoral on sort la
participation de la population est
importante pour les élections
municipales et
élections nationales et il est un peu
moins pour le département mais chacun
connaît son département elle connait son
numéro tous les concitoyens par contre
pour les structures qui ont été créées
depuis
il y a une méconnaissance de nos
concitoyens que ça soit
la région
beaucoup de nos citoyens c'est même pas
dans quelle région font partie il faut
dire que en plus depuis la dernière
réforme certaines régions sont très
grandes
ça multiplié l'éloignement des centres
des centres de décision qui sont devenus
plus loin
en matière de coopération intercommunale
c'est devenu c'est devenu quand même
tout là très flou
même si on si le
les intercommunalités ont permis de
réduire un certain nombre de syndicats
intercommunaux
donc
je pense que il faut aujourd'hui
renforcer quand même ces trois niveaux
et pas les dénaturer
et donc
en matière de péréquation il faudrait
d'abord arrêter d'avoir des outils
antipéritateur nous avons par exemple
une DGF par habitant qui va de suivant
la taille de la commune de 64 euros par
habitant pour les communes rurales à 128
pour les communes de plus de 200 000
habitants c'est contraire à nos
principes de la République un homme égal
une voix pareil au niveau des intercos
on va de 20 euros par habitant à 60
euros par habitant pour les métropoles
c'est contraire aux principes
républicains et en plus ça renforce
cette fracture territoriale il sera bien
à un moment ou un autre remettre les
choses à l'endroit et que les principes
prévus qu'à un homme une voix soit
enfin respecté dans notre République
sinon
aujourd'hui
les forces
extrêmes
se feront entendre pour y arriveront au
pouvoir
donc
aujourd'hui nous avons la chance d'avoir
36000 communes 500 000 conseillers
municipaux bénévoles qui font un travail
au quotidien et je pense pas qu'on
puisse réduire
l'analyse la vie d'une commune au
seulement à ces chiffres ce que
malheureusement la Cour des comptes
semble un peu
ignorer
donc
je suis
aujourd'hui effectivement en matière de
fiscalité il faut comme le disait pierre
une réelle autonomie fiscale
une on a une visibilité une
à la fois la prévisibilité et la
responsabilité je pense que c'est
important aujourd'hui
la taxe
la perte de la taxe d'habitation
a rompu un lien important qui avait
entre la commune et les habitants
aujourd'hui un habitant sur deux ne paye
plus d'impôts local et ce qui est
problématique au niveau de la
responsabilité à la fois on a des
demandes de gens de de nos concitoyens
qui ne finalement ne payent pas d'impôts
c'est une problématique
importante qui à terme va affaiblir
notre socle républicain
la révision des valeurs locatives ne
regrettons qu'elle soit encore reportées
et elle est valeurs locatives je
rappelle sur le foncier bâti et date de
70 et
le report aujourd'hui encore de deux ans
de la révision des valeurs locatives au
niveau de la fiscalité professionnelle
nous inquiète les
commissions départementales avaient fait
un travail important les commissions
communales
beaucoup de bénévoles se sont investis
aussi dedans et
on les a reportés de deux ans je
j'espère qu'on ne sait pas un rapport au
40 grec pour le foncier bâti je vous le
dis je vous rappelle que les valeurs
sont de
1970 depuis la variée d'une manière
importante en fonction de la situation
des communes
et je ne parle pas du foncier non bâti
la qui date de 61 depuis 1961 il y a une
mécanisation importante au niveau
agricole en 1961 c'était les pré qui
étaient estimés qui avait une valeur
bien supérieure au TER agricole ce qui
est l'inverse aujourd'hui là aussi
61 ça fait maintenant plus de 60 ans il
y a urgence à revoir ce système
enfin
ce que
nous
rejetons c'est toutes les perspectives
de vouloir
transformer la la
coopération intercommunale
libre et volontaire par une un
changement de rapport en j'ai vu que il
y avait un souhait de verser la DGF des
communes à l'intercaude cela repartager
ça veut dire que les communes seraient
sous la tutelle des communautés de
communes donc on est complètement à
l'inverse de la coopération
intercommunale et si ce projet était
mis en place ça serait fini de des
communes
donc
nous opposons fermement à tout ce qui
est la coopération forcée et cette mise
sous tutelle
des communes de même
permettre aux conseils communautaire de
modifier les attributions de
compensation la majorité c'est aussi
une manière de de faire une nouvelle
tutelle des
communautés de communes sur les communes
sachant que depuis la loi nôtre
la loi nôtre a complètement
modifiée la coopération intercommunale
puisque là elle a entraîné des
transferts de compétences sans accord
des conseils municipaux et à ce titre
nous dénonçons une
recentralisation
celle qui par exemple nous oblige les
communes à transférer l'eau et
l'assainissement
d'ici 2026 au plus tard
là aussi une coopération et d'autant
plus
vivante qu'elle est libre volontaire
quand elle est imposée
ça pose beaucoup de problèmes et en fait
c'est une des possession
des conseils municipaux et par cette
intermédiaire de la population qui ne se
sont plus responsables
on peut rester là de niveau une vision
première il y aura un deuxième tour
après des les questions de nos collègues
très bien donc je vais maintenant venir
vers Sébastien qui est en visio
et qui donc va maintenant intervenir
Sébastien donc Miossec qui va intervenir
maintenant pour intercommunalité de
France en lui demandant de respecter à
peu près le quart d'heure quoi merci
merci monsieur le Président
cher Claude monsieur le sénateur Husson
à gainé les collègues merci de me
permettre d'intervenir en visio désolé
d'être à distance j'espère que je serai
suffisamment clair malgré la distance et
les contrats de transport qui m'ont pas
permis de rejoindre Paris aujourd'hui
merci d'abord donc à la commission des
finances et de nous inviter ce matin
toutes et tous pour partager ce rapport
merci d'avoir pris l'initiative de
demander à la Cour de mener ce travail
qui qui essaie d'apporter des réponses à
beaucoup de questions que qui sont
parfois de très longue date qui ouvre
aussi un débat donc avec l'État
évidemment entre collectivités entre les
différents niveaux de collectivité donc
ça a été évoqué par mes prédécesseurs ça
pose des questions notamment vis-à-vis
des départements pourquoi pas peut-être
aussi vis-à-vis des régions mais aussi
au sein du bloc communal et donc de
pouvoir entendre les différentes
associations avec chacun des points de
vue qui sont pour partie les partager
pour partie un peu différent doit
nourrir ce travail mais je nous invite à
être vigilants à ce que ce travail
indispensable
ne tombe pas dans le risque de de la
dispute entre nous d'autant plus avec la
le climat financier de 2023 qui est tout
à fait compliqué notamment avec des
coûts de l'énergie qui
peut stresser nos préparations
budgétaires et donc faut qu'on arrive à
prendre sur ce sujet de du financement
des collectivités du recul et de la
hauteur
parce que les constats sont partagés je
veux pas forcément entrer dans le détail
mais les redire quand même ce qui est
important pour intercommunalité de
France dans le dans le dans ce constat
je profite d'ailleurs pour excuser
Sébastien Martin notre président donc la
fiscalité est à bout de souffle c'est un
des titres des des chapitres du rapport
de la Cour donc une fiscalité à votre
souffle a été maintes fois bousculé elle
est aujourd'hui illisible pour beaucoup
nous concitoyens
évidemment et malheureusement mais même
pour nous et du locaux et pour notamment
les élus récents on oublie vite tout ce
qui s'est passé précédemment et tous les
raisons qui ont expliqué tous les
mécanismes de compensation qui ont été
mis en place il y a aussi des
incohérences a été évoquées par mes
intervenants précédents des incohérences
entre les compétences exercées et les
ressources dont on peut bénéficier un
déséquilibre de plus en plus grand aussi
ça n'a pas forcément été évoqué par les
intervenants précédents mais entre la
fiscalité par les ménages de la
fiscalité payée par les entreprises que
un déséquilibre croissant la suppression
de la CVE là encore appuyé là ces
derniers ces derniers temps et donc il
faut qu'on puisse très vigilant à ce
cette contribution je crois que c'est
Pierre qui l'a évoqué
que tous les tous les bénéficiaires des
services publics puissent contribuer de
façon équilibrée au
budget locaux et puis cette inégalité
aussi entre territoires qui est un
[Musique]
comment dire une inquiétude qui est
largement partagée entre nous tous
deuxième élément de constat qui me
semble-t-il partager c'est qu'on sait à
peu près d'ailleurs similaire sur les
dotations et la péréquation beaucoup
beaucoup de divisibilité dans tout ça a
besoin d'y revenir et tout ça mais en
remet en question la capacité des
collectivités à agir en responsabilité
en liberté ça a été c'est des mots qui
ont été déjà été évoqués tout ça soit
bien compris de nos citoyens et de nos
contribuables qui sont d'ailleurs pas
toujours les mêmes donc ces mots
d'autonomie de solidarité de
responsabilité nous les partageons
totalement à intercommunalité de France
sur le fond du rapport quelques quelques
remarques
le scénario
comment dire un peu central qui a été
proposé par la Cour évidemment
[Musique]
toujours y apporter des remarques mais
globalement on peut dire qu'on s'y
retrouve plutôt on se retrouve plutôt
parce que ça croise pas mal de de
propositions que intercommunalité de
France avait pu travailler ces dernières
années proposer dans différentes
auditions notamment au Sénat ou à la
Cour des comptes
on retrouve aussi dans notre Manifeste
qui avait été transmis au candidats aux
élections présidentielles
ce scénario permet d'une certaine façon
de redonner du souffle au bloc local en
lien mettre plus de lien aussi entre les
compétences qu'on exerce à l'échelle du
blog commune communauté et les recettes
notamment notre notre rôle primordial
dans l'aménagement du territoire qui
doit se retrouver aussi dans les
ressources fiscales qu'on peut avoir et
puis le fait de retrouver un peu plus de
pouvoir de taux est aussi une
l'objectif qu'on doit qu'on doit
partager attention toutefois et
finalement je vais aller plutôt sur les
les remarques ou les éléments
d'attention qu'on doit sur lesquels on
veut appuyer attention à d'abord à ce
que un scénario global tel qu'il est
proposé qui fonctionne plutôt bien de
notre point de vue en masse global
attention à ce que ça peut donner à
l'échelon local et on a besoin dans les
étapes on va dire qui suivront les
suites à donner à ce rapport à ce qu'on
soit
courante dans le dans le détail entre
guillemets qu'on puisse voir ce que la
comparaison entre les faits global et
l'effet local on l'a vu notamment sur la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation que
ce qui pouvait globalement marcher je
veux pas sur le fond de la de la réforme
et sur la technique ce qui pouvait
marcher sur le papier derrière avec la
correction du coefficient correcteur ne
marche pas forcément localement et en
tout cas de notre point de vue ne marche
pas du tout sur le talon
donc on a besoin de partager des données
donc les données que dont l'état dispose
et puis de pouvoir voilà à creuser les
scénarios pour voir ce que ça peut
donner parce que ça corrige mais ce que
ça peut éventuellement impliquer l'effet
indésirables attention aussi aux
situations très hétérogènes de nos de
nos territoires
hétérogène parce qu'on a une diversité
de de territoires avec des territoires
très dynamiques
souvent le fait urbain comme dans le
plus dynamique mais c'est pas toujours
le cas inversement il y a aussi beaucoup
de territoire euros qui sont fragiles
mais reconnaissons aussi qu'il y a
quelques territoires héros qui sont en
Ford dynamisme et donc cette
hétérogénéité des territoires et il faut
qu'on puisse la la l'identifier et la
corriger notamment par la péréquation et
aussi pourquoi pas on n'est pas opposé
même si ça doit rester
plus ou moins marginal par des partages
d'impôts nationaux comme ça a été le cas
par la TVA beaucoup de nos
interconnalités adhérentes nous disent
que
d'avoir une part de TVA dans ses
recettes c'est ça peut être aussi un
effet positif ça peut aussi avoir des
effets positifs pardon dans le dans le
planning de ressources
l'hétérogénéité on la retrouve aussi
dans la diversité de l'Organisation
Locale de nid durant a évoqué à
l'instant un peu de d'histoire de la
construction de nos institutions et de
la République
aujourd'hui faisons le constat quand
même que la France n'est pas celle d'y a
quelques décennies et voir plus loin que
la République a permis par le fait
intercommunal avec pour l'essentiel la
volonté des élus même si c'est pas le
lieu mais peut avoir un débat sur les
compétences qui ont été transféré de
façon obligatoire mais globalement
l'essentiel de la coopération
intercommunale elle est née quand même
des syndicats et de l'histoire qui se
sont qui se sont construits d'abord par
la volonté des élus et donc on a
aujourd'hui une diversité très forte des
1200 bassins intercommunaux avec une
organisation des compétences des
transferts de charge des pacte
financiers fiscaux qui font que à chaque
territoire correspond à une réalité qui
n'est pas forcément la même à l'échelle
de des intercommunalité et donc c'est
évoqué dans le rapport de la Cour il
faut qu'on puisse travailler c'est
notre point de vue à intercommunalité de
France qu'on puisse travailler davantage
à l'échelle de l'ensemble intercommunale
pour regarder les écarts de recherche et
de et de charge
évidemment en ayant une vigilance
absolue à respecter l'autonomie
communale donc on n'est pas
spontanément favorable à la DGF
intercommunale c'est-à-dire que
l'interco récupère l'ensemble de la DGF
du bloc commune communauté et la
redistribue si c'est une volonté des
élus locaux à l'échelle de l'ensemble
intercommunale pourquoi pas mais ça ne
peut pas être à ce stade en tout cas une
obligation parce qu'aujourd'hui les
conditions sont pas du tout du tout
réunies donc intercommunalité de France
la plupart forcément là-dessus mais de
de ça nous paraît tout de même impératif
de regarder la diversité de la France
par cette ce prisme de l'ensemble
intercommunal j'ai conscience que ça
ça peut lever des inquiétudes ça peut
soulever les inquiétudes pardon et
justement l'enjeu c'est de lever ces
inquiétudes là pour que on travaille en
pleine confiance il y a des endroits où
l'intercommunité de marche pas très bien
il faut le reconnaître mais ça reste
très marginal et beaucoup d'endroits
l'interco elle permet justement de
construire des solidarités totalement
adaptées à la réalité du territoire
solidarité par l'exercice des
compétences mais aussi par la fiscalité
par le partage de ressources
et donc on doit se doter d'outils pour
construire ces solidarités territoriales
entre nous et il faut aussi que la
nation puisse
comparer les territoires en tenant
compte de cette diversité
donc voilà donc c'est pour moi un des
champs qu'on doit encore pouvoir
travailler davantage j'ajoute un élément
sur le
qui nous invite aussi à beaucoup
réfléchir c'est le la question du zan le
zéro artificialisation net le Sénat
notamment a beaucoup travaillé là-dessus
c'est-à-dire que de France rencontre
Jean-Baptiste blanc et Valérie d'État
dans vos collègues sénateurs qui ont
travaillé aussi sur ce sujet on les
rencontre cet après-midi et si ça pose
des questions en matière de
d'urbanisme on va dire au sens large ça
pose aussi beaucoup de questions
financières et fiscales et donc je sais
le Sénat attentif à ce sujet là mais
dans ce scénario des financement il faut
qu'on puisse aussi intégrer cet élément
là puisque beaucoup de notre fiscalité
de notre capacité à lever de l'impôt est
assis aujourd'hui sur sur le foncier et
donc on doit on doit y travailler à la
fois urgemment même si
le rapport qui nous réunissent ce matin
nous invite plutôt à regarder sur le
temps mais dans le temps long évidemment
mais dans le temps court notamment pour
contrecarrer certains effets
indésirables de la de la Duane et puis
d'ailleurs la refonte des valeurs
locatives j'appuie puisque mes collègues
ont dit c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
qu'elle soit reportée pour merci
Sébastien si tu pouvais conclure à ton
propos 30 secondes je suis à moins de 10
minutes donc j'essaie de faire 11
minutes
et donc chantier très lourd le CFL
justement doit être un le lieu de notre
point de vue où on y travaille mais il
faut vraiment qu'on questionne la façon
dont le c'est fait l'organise ses
travaux je jette pas la pierre du tout à
au président mais on a besoin de pouvoir
anticiper de travailler dans le temps de
peut-être d'ajuster aussi la composition
du CFA tout ça nous demandera aussi du
temps
et donc faut que le Parlement est
gouvernement puisse dire aussi ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire de tout ça que que
nous et l'association les locaux
puissent aussi travailler collectivement
et puis enfin sur le soutien
d'investissement
c'est un sujet aussi
central et indispensable dans le dans le
vu la situation et le besoin du pays
d'investir et la recommandation du de la
chambre de travail sur des dispositifs
contractualisés ça nous va plutôt très
bien ça doit encourager l'état être plus
annuel on sait faire ça avec nos
départements nos régions de regarder à
l'échelle du lancement intercommunal ça
nous paraît aussi
utile même si là aussi il est pas
question de tutelle de l'interpro sur
les communes et de discussion collective
avec nos interlocuteurs on le fait avec
les régions et les départements dans la
plupart de nos territoires donc on va
aussi pouvoir le faire avec l'État donc
désolé d'avoir été peut-être un peu long
mais merci encore de tout ça et puis
surtout au travail collectivement parce
que on voit qu'il y a plein de questions
et d'enjeux
sur lequel on coupe on partage beaucoup
de choses merci merci Sébastien comme il
est de tradition je vais demander
tout d'abord peut-être à nos collègues
sénateurs d'apporter leurs questions de
manière à ce que ensuite la course elle
le souhaite puis se répondre un peu
collectivement si je peux dire
l'ensemble des sujets traités qu'ils
soient traités par les représentants des
associations que l'on vient d'attendre
un peu longuement mais c'était l'idée
non mais c'était l'idée de vous donner
la parole assez longuement et je sais
que nos collègues sénateurs ont
traditionnellement la capacité de faire
une synthèse de leurs interrogations à
peu près deux minutes chacun grand
maximum et nous allons de pour donner
l'exemple parce que ça vaut des lignes
me paraît tout trouver et donc il va il
va démarrer
Eric Bocquet suivra
monsieur le président
[Musique]
moi j'ai une question d'abord vous
évoquez dans votre rapport les dotations
de l'État serait rationalisés je trouve
que le mot rationaliser mérite d'être
explicité d'autant que je comprends pas
pourquoi quand on parle du bloc communal
vous dites que il faut atteindre
l'équilibre financier et quand on parle
des départements et régions vous fixez
d'autres objectifs c'est une vraie
question et donc le premier indication
de ma part moi je serai pour qu'on
bouscule la hiérarchie de tout ça
c'est-à-dire qu'on commence par le bloc
communal et qu'après on monte en grade
sur les compétences des départements et
des régions la deuxième chose que je
voudrais vous poser c'est qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de deux impôts il y a
beaucoup d'impôts qui sont particuliers
je pense au DMTO qui sont quand même sur
une dynamique spéculative et la TVA qui
mais ça n'engage que moi m'apparaît
comme un impôt quand même des plus
injuste quelle est la part que près de
ces deux impôts dans l'autonomie des
collectivités territoriales deuxième
question
la troisième question c'est je vous le
dis
je pense qu'on a besoin de votre aide et
y compris de nos aides notre aide
collective ici je n'en peux plus
d'entendre sur certains sujets que
l'impôt serait confisque à toi parce que
quand on développe cette idée là on
porte atteinte aussi à l'un pour local
donc il faut qu'on arrive les uns les
autres dans notre diversité mais à faire
un lien entre impôts et démocratie
locale et je pense que votre rapport
doit contribuer va contribuer à ça et
dernière petite question technique aussi
vous le savez comme moi dans ce qu'on
appelle les camembert de répartition des
recettes de financement des
collectivités territoriales les trois
niveaux d'échelons on reste dans vos
scénarios à toujours 7% pour l'emprunt
est-ce que la chambre a une innovation
une créativité qui permettrait de donner
une visibilité et un rapport au temps
pour les collectivités sur cette
question de l'emprunt notamment en
termes d'investissement public puisque
là on reste dans les mêmes proportions
c'est 7% dans la proportionnalité merci
j'ai fait deux 9 secondes oui ça pas
tout à fait été dans le contrat je l'ai
noté Méric Bocquet va corriger
merci monsieur le Président j'ai pas
vraiment de questions mais beaucoup plus
un constat général par rapport à ce
qu'on vient d'entendre qui sont des
propos extrêmement intéressants et
importants et je reprends l'expression
de Françoise Samuel qui a rappelé cette
espèce de postulat permanent depuis
quelques décennies de considérer que les
collectivités sont dépensières et que
donc il faut les brider qu'il faut
réduire leur dépenses etc ce discours là
ne varie pas sont considérés comme une
variable d'ajustement et dans la période
comme vous tous nous assistons nombreux
aux cérémonies de voeux dans nos
territoires dans le département
respectifs et les maires nous expliquent
leur bilan leur projet leurs difficultés
aussi et on entend par exemple des
maires qui explique partout pour réduire
la facture énergétique qu'on remplace
les ampoules au sodium par des ampoules
LED que l'on installe des cités de
récupération d'eau pluviales qui
permettent de récupérer l'eau pluviale
avec laquelle on va pouvoir arroser les
fleurs cet été que on va isoler
thermiquement les bâtiments etc bref
entre les engagements nécessaires
importants pris dans les cops au niveau
international on se dit que la réponse
une grande partie de la réponse se passe
dans les communes dans les territoires
avec l'investissement des communes donc
il faudrait vraiment sortir de cette
logique qui consiste à considérer les
collectivités comme une variable
d'ajustement elles sont un puissant
levier d'investissement elles ont des
budgets équilibrés elles ne sont en rien
la cause du déficit de 3000 milliards de
notre dette publique nationale et leur
endettement elles investissent elles
empruntent pour investir et le
rendêtement est parfaitement maîtrisé
puisqu'il représente 8 9% au mieux de la
dette publique globale alors les
discours qu'on entend après la RGPP
qu'on a eu on a eu la map également
monétisation de l'action publique là on
nous parle d'action publique 2022 est
toujours cette constante réduire la
dépense publique et j'entends encore les
vœux de Monsieur Bruno Le Maire le 5
janvier dernier qui disait on va
procéder à des revues des public et je
le cite ces revues de dépenses publiques
devront concerner toutes les dépenses
publiques sans exception l'État mais
aussi celle des collectivités
territoriales alors je me dis que quand
j'entends les mers qui se débrouillent
comme des bons pour avancer pour
investir pour répondre aux grandes
préoccupations du moment et qu'ils
entendent en même temps ce grand
discours de réduction des dépenses
publiques je crois que André leniel au
maire de France a fait le compte il y a
quelques semaines ce sont 46 milliards
d'euros qui ont été économisés par les
collectivités ces dernières années donc
voilà donc la Cour des comptes nous
parle de nécessaire autonomie et de
responsabilité j'adhère complètement à
ses principes mais il faut que ça se
traduis ensuite en acte au niveau de
l'exécutif pour donner les moyens aux
collectivités ça a été rappelé par nos
amis des mers ruraux et Monsieur brutaux
des maires de France pour répondre aux
grands défis du moment ici et ailleurs
merci
finalement l'intervention de Pascal
Savoldelli était parfaite
je parle pas des contenus bien entendu
Antoine Lefebvre puis Vanina Paoli Gaja
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de faire mieux alors notre
chambre a mis fin dans la loi de
finances rectification pour 2022 à
l'obligation qui était faite aux
communes de reverser un fragment de
texte d'aménagement aux EPCI ce qui
s'est inscrit très favorablement dans la
défense des libertés locales alors je
souhaite apporter une réflexion sur la
taxe d'aménagement justement qui
représentait une ressource fiscale de
1,2 milliards d'euros pour le bloc
communal 600 millions pour le
département et je pense à un certain
nombre d'infrastructures que les
communes vont être appelées à multiplier
sur leur territoire notamment avec le
développement des mobilités douces alors
une élue de mon département vient de me
département de l'Aisne vient de
m'interroger justement sur
la possibilité pour sa commune d'être
exonérée de cet axe d'aménagement sur
une aire de covoiturage elle avait
récemment fait aménagée et on lui oppose
une fin de non-recevoir alors est-ce
qu'on peut songer justement à une
évolution de l'assiette de cet axe
d'aménagement qui favoriserait justement
des exonérations d'infrastructures qui
sont susceptibles d'être reconnus
d'utilité publique et de compenser en
fait les pertes par des augmentations de
taux sur d'autres infrastructures qui
peuvent être moins vertueux sur le plan
environnemental voilà un peu l'objet de
ma question merci Antoine je vois
connais comme toujours on élargit un peu
le sujet par rapport je suis pas sûr que
dans le rapport de la Cour des comptes
il y a eu beaucoup de choses sur la taxe
d'aménagement mais
c'est logique
Vanina pas obligé puis Sébastien Meurant
oui merci monsieur le Président merci au
président de la cour pour sa
présentation aux différents intervenants
des organisations je ne repartirai pas
monsieur le Président sur le postulat
qui a été retenu pour votre analyse mon
voisin je pense va le faire mais je
pense que lorsqu'on est depuis si
longtemps dans une impasse systémique
telle que on la connaît en la matière
c'est un peu
ça interpelle en fait et on ne sait plus
vraiment si il s'agit de fermentation ou
de fossilisation donc je vais pas
m'étendre sur le sujet j'ai deux
questions et peut-être une suggestion la
première question elle concerne le pic
qui pique beaucoup nos élus locaux il
s'agit vous le savez d'un outil de
péréquation en fait qui d'abord ne
devait être que temporaire or je
constate qu'il est toujours pleinement
en action
il fait partie des modèles financiers
des communes et des intercos
en milieu rural de nombreuses communes
critiquent la clé de répartition du pic
puisqu'elle favorise les grosses
intercos c'est tout à fait le cas dans
mon département de l'eau puisque 80% va
à la métropole
les maires ont le sentiment qu'on leur
demande des efforts en fait pour
financer le budget de la métropole ce
qui n'est pas personnellement ma vision
de ce qu'est une péréquation qu'elle
soit horizontale ou verticale que
pensez-vous de ces critiques sur ces
clés de répartition du pic j'ai proposé
à plusieurs reprises des amendements
pour les modifier je n'ai pas réussi à
prospérer malheureusement mais
j'aimerais bien avoir votre vision sur
ce sujet deuxième question c'est une
question qui concerne les dotations de
l'État aux collectivités qui sont censés
viser des objectifs de politique
publique je pense par exemple à la
dotation biodiversité qui peut être
faite à certaines communes je
m'interroge comment est-il possible que
certaines communes puissent les
percevoir sans que on ne s'intéresse aux
conditions
d'affectation réelle en fait de ces
dotations je
m'interroge sur ce sujet
et enfin j'ai une suggestion la
mobilisation de nouvelles sources de
financement notamment privée n'apparaît
absolument pas en fait dans le rapport
on nous propose des scénaristes soit
avec plus de dotation soit avec plus de
fiscalité locale est-ce que cette
troisième voie pour penser un peu
autrement et exploitable explorable ou
non je pense par exemple à l'amendement
que j'ai porté qui permet de ouvrir le
mécénat aux communes forestières est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas imaginer d'autres
pistes pour le financement de nos
collectivités je vous remercie merci
Vanina Sébastien me rend depuis
Dominique delège merci monsieur le
Président merci à tous les intervenants
je sais que c'est pour remettre en cause
le postulat de départ mais moi si il y a
quelque chose qui pourrait tous nous
réunir c'est l'indigeste millefeuille
territorial
on a rajouté des couches puis les années
et les avant de parler de la question du
financement et de répartition ne faut-il
pas d'abord se poser la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on garde qu'est-ce qu'on
supprime et les locaux que nous sommes
nombreux easy évidemment
constatons année après un excès de plus
en plus difficile lorsqu'on est perdu
une commune de faire des projets
lorsqu'on est au sein des
intercommunalités comme une
agglomération des métropoles etc etc etc
avant de parler de comment on répartit
les prélèvements entre les différentes
collectivités la question essentielle me
semble-t-il c'est que je pense
permettrait de rassembler la nageur
partie des élus ici présents c'est
est-ce qu'on se pose la question
qu'est-ce qu'on garde et qu'est-ce qu'on
supprime et surtout quand on s'aide la
façon ont été créés les grandes régions
les métropoles donc ça je sais que ça
sort du postulat de départ mais ça me
semble d'abord la question qu'on doit se
poser et
devant les citoyens devant les locaux et
après on pourra envisager de répartir
intelligemment les ressources et comme
me disaient nos collègues Boquet tout à
l'heure heureusement qu'il y a les
maires des villes et des villages avec
qui ne compte pas leur temps pour faire
fonctionner notre beau pays et ses
petites cités de la République parce que
là ce sont des des millions d'heures de
bénévolats qui permettent de répondre
aux citoyens et de faire vivre la
démocratie au plus près et à démocratie
qui vit qui investit qui fonctionne qui
se débrouille qui supportent les
amendements les réglementations donc
mais avant tout qu'est-ce qu'on supprime
merci Sébastien je suis pas sûr que
cette question soit majoritairement
portée par notre assemblée je mets ça un
peu en doute mais au-delà de ça là votre
propos est très clair Dominique delaige
puis daniel Merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais commencer en disant que je
souscris aux propos de Pascal
salvaudélie et d'Eric Bocquet ce qui va
me permettre d'aborder d'autres sujets
et ma première question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
l'autonomie financière l’étonomie
fiscale on est autonome par rapport à
quoi et par rapport à qui je crois qu'on
se fait un peu plaisir avec ce concept
en ce qui concerne l'autonomie fiscale
moi je suis tout à fait favorable mais
quand il y a rien à prélever en matière
de fiscalité bien évidemment que il y a
une question et qu'on souhaite de la
péréquation tant qu'à l'autonomie moi je
ne demande pas mieux que d'être autonome
mais enfin nous recourons régulièrement
à des fonds particuliers qui a pu
constituer l'état je pense à la duotière
au FSI etc donc on se fait plaisir en se
disant qu'on est autonome mais on l'est
pas véritablement sur le plan financier
alors on a à peu près la possibilité de
dépenser le budget comme on veut dans le
cadre réglementaire mais je pense que
cette notion d'autonomie mériterait
d'être affiné et précisé deuxièmement ce
qui concerne les instances de
concertation il y a tellement
d'instances de concertation qu'on peut
bien en créer une de plus mais ce que je
constate c'est que le CFL c'est
conclusion de son pas toujours prises en
considération le Sénat fait plutôt bien
son boulot me semble-t-il c'est pas pour
autant que nos propositions sont prises
en considération donc une nouvelle
instance si c'est pour causer et ne pas
voir les propositions qu'elle formule
plus aboutir que aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas certain que ce soit la bonne réponse
sur la complexité moi ce que j'observe
c'est que à chaque fois qu'on fait une
réforme on crée une exception pour
permettre à des gens de garder ou à des
communes de garder des droits acquis
donc plus on réforme paradoxalement plus
on crée des exceptions donc
faudrait ma question de la façon
suivante est-ce que avec une enveloppe
constante on est capable de faire une
véritable réforme parce que chacun
attend de la réforme d'avoir plus et à
tout le mois de ne pas avoir moins donc
si vous pouviez nous éclairer sur ce
point je ne regretterai pas ma matinée
merci
merci Dominique
Daniel Breuillet puis Stéphane Sautarel
merci je vais commencer par une
conviction les lois de décentralisation
ont apporté beaucoup d'améliorations de
renforcement des solidarités de la
cohésion sociale dans les territoires et
donner un souffle incroyable et si on
questionne nos concitoyens leur réponse
sont majoritairement celles-là et moi
j'ai le sentiment depuis quelques années
pas mal d'années d'ailleurs dans un
étrange mariage entre jacobinisme d'État
et libéralisme au fond on essaye
d'affaiblir sans cesse cette vision
décentralisatrice et de transformer les
maires en sous-préfet anémié avec des
moyens qui leur sont donnés chichement
et une capacité à agir en lien avec leur
population ou les entreprises du
territoire qui est sans cesse affaiblie
et donc je voudrais pousser un coup de
gueule qui est dire laissons les
collectivités locales le bloc communal
vivre laissons-le je vais prendre un
exemple l'exemple beaucoup de communes
sont en train de souffrir par
l'accumulation de logements vacants
d'Airbnb ou les difficultés du zen et
bien je ne crois pas ce sera l'État
jacobin qui trouvera les meilleures
réponses à ces questions et par exemple
nous allons porter c'est une page de
publicité une PPL pour demander qu'on
laisse au groupe local la possibilité de
d'avoir des taxes sur les résidences
secondaires ou sur bon mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'à chaque fois l'exemple de
François Rebsamen ou de ou du
représentants de la MF je sais plus sur
les taxes locales de publicité ces taxes
sont des outils d'aménagement du
territoire ce sont des choix qui nous
permettent de transformer nos villes ça
n'est pas seulement une recette et donc
l'état chaque fois qu'on veut créer une
recette regarde maintenant dans les
collectivités territoriales
effectivement comme des dépensiers qui
ne font que générer de la recette et
bien c'est dépensier il génère de la
cohésion sociale et je finirai là-dessus
dans la crise démocratique que nous
vivons
et qui que nous devrions regarder comme
premier sujet la confiance aux
collectivités territoriales et peut-être
la réponse la plus efficace que nous
pourrons apporter pas la seule il faut
aussi de l'état aujourd'hui on parle du
bloc communal en tous les cas voilà vive
la biodiversité y compris la
biodiversité des choix politiques
territoriaux défendant les et
renforçons-les par les propositions que
nous adopterons peut-être un jour
parfait je pense que nous aurons une
réponse de Monsieur Charpy tout à
l'heure sur le sujet
Stéphane Stéphane Sautarel puis
Christian Billac
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de m'en tenir à ce qui a été
présenté par par les représentants des
différentes associations du bloc
communal tout d'abord pour pour
reprendre l'idée que les finances
publiques sont bien une question
politique une question démocratique au
service en fait de des politiques
locales et de l'exercice des libertés
locales pour reprendre un peu le les
propos de
montrer nécessaire et à ce titre là
effectivement la gouvernance ne peut ne
doit émaner que des élus dans un cadre
qui qui doit être construit par une
évolution des dispositifs en place j'ai
trois questions m'ont fait une qui porte
sur la notion de de l'autonomie fiscale
alors effectivement autonomie fiscale
autonomie financière mais sur
l'autonomie fiscale en particulier sur
la vision puisque ça pas été développé
des représentants des associations
d'élus sur ce que devrait être pour être
à l'impôt résidentiel et et qu'elles en
serait la portée éventuelle l'intérêt
qu'ils y verraient et la portée que ça
pourrait avoir y compris au niveau de la
nature des contribuables puisque j'ai
bien entendu que ça pouvait être assez
large ma deuxième question c'est sur la
prise en compte au-delà des ressources
au delà des moyens des niveaux de charge
est-ce que en terme d'équité
territoriale la question de la dépense
la question des charges d'une norme
éventuellement de dépenses est-elle un
point qui recueille un avis et quel avis
des représentants des associations du
bloc communal et enfin une question un
peu plus précise ça a été évoqué par
François Asselin autour du FC TVA qui ne
doit pas devenir une dotation mais
est-ce que le TVA peut rester à
contrario ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et
donc est-ce qu'il y a des pistes
d'évolution
que vous proposeriez au niveau
spécifiquement de ce FC TVA merci
Stéphane Christian BIAC puis Marc laminy
merci monsieur le président
oui je crois que tout le monde le
partage la l'analyse de la Cour des
comptes sur la complexité le manque de
lisibilité et le prévisibilité en ce qui
concerne des finances locales mais je
crois président que vous avez conclu
avant de commencer
c'est difficile de changer
je voudrais dire que il faudrait cesser
de penser qu'on vit dans un pays qui
s'appelle la théorie mais bien être
conscient convient en France parce qu'en
France quand il y a un problème de
transport et bien les gens ils s'en
foutent que ce soit la région ou la
métropole ils vont engueuler le maire et
un problème d'ordure il s'en que
ce soit l'intercommunettes machin ils
vont engueuler le maire et je m'arrête
là parce que je pourrais vous faire une
liste longue comme le bras donc je crois
qu'il ne faut pas oublier ça que le
maire il est en première ligne et que
les concitoyens dans le magma
administratif il ne connaît aucune
personne responsable de tout c'est le
maire et que la jupilerité ça doit nous
guider alors moi je relèverai la
tendance à remplacer l'impôt par les
d'autres agents et une tendance très
ancienne puisque toutes les dotations
correspondent à l'impôt supprimé toute
alors faut-il y voir une défiance envers
les élus
on peut s'interroger
et revenir sur l'autonomie entre la
différence entre autonomie financière et
autonomie fiscale et là je rejoins
Pascal chevaux de libre j'ai vu la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen dans mon bureau depuis que je
suis élu et j'y reviens toujours pas que
c'est le fondement de République et bien
elle dit qu'il y a une contribution qui
est également répartie entre tous les
citoyens en fonction de leur facultés
pour entretenir l'action publique et je
crois qu'il faut pas l'oublier et
l'impôt c'est important alors la courbe
en touche sur le nouvel impôt
résidentiel après avoir étudié les
avantages et les inconvénients mais on
ne sait pas trop quel elle boitante
touche mais il en reste aussi injuste
que la taxe habitation qu'on a supprimé
sous ce motif
effectivement qui est pas très juste
mais il y a aussi la taxe foncière qui a
les mêmes bases que le taxe d'habitation
et puis la taxe d'ordure qui aujourd'hui
contrairement à la taxe foncière à la
taxe d'habitation qui bénéficie les
bénéficier d’allagement pour les
personnes âgées modestes etc la taxe
d'ordures elle frappe de plein fouet nos
concitoyens avec une remise en cause
parce qu'avec
cette taxe formate on entend de plus en
plus ce refrain maintenant ça suffit
plus on trip plus on paye enfin il y a
vraiment un sujet au niveau de la
fiscalité locale et donc moi je crois
que avec ces
réflexions de la cour on avance un peu
mais si on veut pas faire de politique
un peu dans les finances on fait rien
parce que le final c'est que la
traduction de politique
merci
on est dans une terre de rugby ne voyez
pas le moteur touche autrement que comme
une expression populaire du sud de la
France voilà
Marc laminy puis Vincent et merci
monsieur le Président merci à nous
inviter la Cour des comptes et les
représentants des élus des territoires
merci de vos autres contribution alors
je m'adresse
représentant de la Cour des comptes sur
le Président Madame mesdames
simplement sur les sept recommandations
est-ce qu'on a une idée un petit peu de
l'échéancier dont le temps
d'autre part
doit-on créer une autorité indépendante
parce que c'est déjà compliqué il y a
déjà beaucoup d'intervenants au scénario
aussi une délégation collectivité
territoriale bon c'est vrai il y a quand
même un travail de fond et les
représentants des des élus je dirais
témoigne aussi largement et
interviennent largement
il est vrai que l'État reste le premier
financeur des collectivités
territoriales du chiffre ont été
rappelés au-delà bien au-delà de 100
milliards d'euros concernant j'irai
l'autonomie financière va se sujet on
tout a été bien bien résumé alors il y a
un niveau de tête qui n'a pas été abordé
c'est l'Europe
la complexité des dossiers on le connaît
mais les dossiers l'Europe peut aussi
aider les collectivités territoriales
mais je dirais beaucoup renonce
tellement les dossiers sont complexes
voilà c'était un petit peu mes
interrogations et je vous en remercie
merci Marc Vincent et blé pyjama et
mizon oui merci monsieur le Président
merci l'initiative de ce débat
qu'évidemment est un sujet qui passionne
au Sénat
pour ma part je suis depuis longtemps
assez perplexe sur l'observation d'une
contradiction assez forte qui existe
quand j'observe que tout à la fois les
collectivités réclament de l'autonomie
fiscale et sont favorables aux
dispositif généraux de péréquation pour
aider les plus pauvres j'y trouve là un
espace de contradiction parce que la
richesse n'est pas répartie de façon
homogène sur le territoire donc réclamer
de pouvoir prélever sur une richesse
locale par le vote d'un taux un produit
c'est évidemment ne pas régler la
question la péréquation et du coup je me
suis toujours interrogé sur le point de
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne met pas
en place des dispositifs de péréquation
non pas sur le produit une fois qu'il
est connu pour prendre à ceux qui en ont
trop pour donner à ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas assez ce qui en plus
provoque des effets évidemment de
crispation de mécontentements parce que
on pense pouvoir bénéficier d'un produit
et puis au bout du compte on ne l'a pas
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne met pas en
place dispositif de peréquation sur les
bases
ce qui nécessiterait évidemment que une
part du produit fiscal soit sur un taux
identique tout territoire confondu parce
qu'on ne voit pas une assemblée
territoriale votée un taux pour un
prélèvement dans la commune d'à côté ou
dans les communes d'à côté sur la base
d'une péréquation donc une part avec un
taux fixe qui pourrait faire l'objet
d'une forme de péréquation et ensuite
un produit par
défiscalités locales qui
disparaissent progressivement et qui
elle j'irai permettrait de maintenir une
forme de responsabilisation des élus
dans un territoire eu égard à la
pression fiscale que qui s'exerce sur
leur mandat est-ce que cette piste de
péréquation des bases a été examinée à
un moment ou un autre
merci Vincent d'ailleurs vous pouvez
j'ai fermé la liste chers amis parce que
sinon on peut plus on peut plus y
arriver mais simplement
sur cette question toujours pareil de
l'autonomie fiscale on relève toujours
quand même que 80% des communes quand
elles font leur bilan de mandat soulève
le fait qu'elles n'ont pas augmenté les
impôts
quand elles font leur projet de mandat
qu'elles ne vont pas le faire
c'est vrai que demander une autonomie
fiscale à des gens qui ne veulent pas
utiliser l'outil fiscal
il y a un truc non je le dis il y a un
truc il y a un problème il y a un sujet
je vous le mets dans la tête ça pose des
questions alors on a les deux derniers
parce que je suis obligé d'arrêter
Jean-Marie maison sachant que la semaine
prochaine nous avons une autre séance
encore je le dis pour le collègue les
collègues qui souhaiteraient encore
s'exprimer mais il faut qu'on passe vers
les conclusions Jean-Marie maison puis
Jean-Claude Roquier merci monsieur le
Président moi j'ai une observation et
une question l'observation concerne le
rapport bien sûr de la cour qui
observe que à partir de 2014 les
dépenses de fonctionnement en
saguièrement augmenté alors que dans le
même temps il n'y a pas eu de mouvement
de décentralisation marquée
d'ailleurs la cour l'observe mais dans
la même période il y a eu néanmoins des
réformes territoriales
qui ont amené les territoires à être
plus gros pour précisément faire des
économies d'échelle et il s'est passé ce
qui se passe systématiquement dans le
secteur public quand on regroupe
ça devient plus cher
je pense en particulier
au conseil régional Grand Est qui réunit
maintenant 10 départements et la chambre
ne constate pas un constat précisément
que c'est plus cher pour tout le monde
ça c'est l'observation la question est
la suivante quand le président de la
République a initié la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation elle avait mis en
avant deux éléments le premier c'était
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
et le deuxième c'était
mettre fin à une injustice
moi j'observe que la le fond en attaque
sur le fond chez bâti est assise
sur la même base la moitié la moitié
d'une injustice ça reste néanmoins une
injustice et si on voulait demain
redonner encore du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français ce qui n'est pas impossible à
imaginer
et que donc on supprimerait la taxe sur
le foncier bâti comme on l'a supprimé
c'est le la taxe d'habitation que
deviendrait l'excellent rapport de la
Cour des comptes à quoi nous
servirait-il alors
merci Jean-Marie juste un explication tu
as peut-être oublié que les élus locaux
ont eux-mêmes creusé la tombe de la taxe
d'habitation parce que si Ana qui ont
dit dès le départ et de manière très
large que la taxe d'habitation était
injuste c'est bien les élus locaux donc
voilà nous n'oublions pas comment les
choses se font et d'ailleurs ça doit
nous permettre d'être prudent sur les
sujets qui nous restent quoi bon
Jean-Claude requier et puis je
repêcherai notre dernier collègue bien
entendu ce qu'il y en a plus que
Jean-Claude
pour un peu de temps mon collègue je
suis tout à fait d'accord sur le Costa
de la course sur un système de
financement jugé à bout de souffle c'est
pas l'exemple de la DGF ça a été dit la
vérité de très bonnes choses quand elle
a été créée je crois que ces histoires
qu'il avait écrit à l'époque et elle a
donné aux communes mais on a réformé la
DGS mais chaque fois qu'on a réformé on
a tout ralenti d'avoir de tout garantir
garantie rien et on a aucune possibilité
de réforme et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Antoine Lefebvre quand il
a dit que pour informer la légère il
faut l'avoir du gras moudre et quand il
y a pas les grammes il faut prendre un
poids propre et chaque fois qu'on fait
en causonné finance on a fait des
simulations on fait tourner les
ordinateurs et on doit forcément des
communes d'un département qui vont
perdre dans bien entendu on est plus
d'accord et puis on repousse la réforme
deuxième chose l'impôt résidentiel mais
côté pourquoi pas c'est vrai qu'il y a
des gens qui sont dans les communes et
qui n'aimaient pas l'impôt communaux qui
souvent demande beaucoup d'ailleurs et
je serai peut-être bien de mettre un
beau réel et puis ça a travaillé et
troisième chose c'est les MTO alors les
enlever au département pour les passer
aux communes c'est une bombe une bombe
fiscale ça c'était parce que parfois on
le remplace mais après tout pourquoi pas
moi je suis l'une du lot on a des
quelques dia météo pour pas trop c'est
vraiment plus que à l'Auvergne et par
contre 14 camps aux Alpes-Maritimes ou à
Paris bien évidemment on serait pas pour
on serait favorable à une péréquation
merci Jean-Claude et donc Didier Rambaud
alors pour te remercier et saluer
l'honnêteté intellectuelle du président
Claude rénal au sujet de l'autonomie
fiscale effectivement je pense qu'il
faut lever un peu une hypocrisie et là
j'interpelle les associations d'élus
quelle est aux dernières élections
municipales tous les candidats quelle
est la seule liste qui a affiché que on
souhaite disposer du levier fiscal je
vais même la faiblesse de penser que la
la première proposition dans tous les
programmes municipaux c'est dire nous ne
toucherons pas aux impôts locaux voire
pas même certains
voilà donc je pense qu'il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie qui fallait un petit peu un
peu lever
je l'ai pas dit comme ça exactement
je me permets pas de porter un terme
aussi mais il y a un constat voilà il y
a des constats qu'on peut partager et on
peut regarder la littérature sur ce plan
là bien
comment dire je vais donner la parole
bien sûr
Christian chapitre saluer madame Lignot
le loup
appeler Madame la rapporteur mais elle a
aussi un nom
et et donc la remercier également pour
son travail et vous demandez comme
toujours un exercice de synthèse qui
vous est familier de répondre à tout ça
à toutes ces interrogations ces
questions assez remarques de manière la
plus synthétique possible monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
mais merci aussi aux rapporteur général
à Monsieur Guenet qui nous ont
accompagné pour ses travaux et merci au
Sénat d'avoir demande à la Cour de faire
ce travail-là qui était pour nous très
passionnant et je vois aussi que ce
travail a intéressé
beaucoup de questions ont été posées je
vais donc pas pouvoir répondre à toutes
mais je voudrais mettre la chanson sur
plusieurs points le premier point c'est
un point de consensus je crois que tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fait que 1
le système est à bout de souffle et deux
que le besoin de visibilité
pour les élus locaux pour les
responsables locaux est un sujet majeur
et qu'aujourd'hui cette visibilité n'est
pas n'est pas assurée je crois qu'on
peut le dire alors on a fait des
propositions
d'avoir la première visibilité ça
pourrait être une loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui donne un
cadre elle est compliquée aujourd'hui
la seconde visibilité c'est d'avoir une
instance alors l'idée de l'instant c'est
pas pour créer un machin de plus on
s'est posé la question le sentiment
c'est qu'il faut un endroit où ces
questions de visibilité d'évolution de
partage de ressources de respect des
principes de de responsabilité de
compensation soit traitée qu'aujourd'hui
le mandat du CFL est un peu restreint
par rapport à ça il est trop restreint
ça responsa ça sa composition n'est pas
non plus parfaite donc soit on rénove
assez profondément le CFN soit en créer
une instance un peu plus politique un
peu plus générale c'est un choix qui est
qui nous a dépassé mais il nous PA
important de le dire second point sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est que on
a travaillé à partir de l'existant et
d'existence c'est un mouvement depuis
plusieurs années qui a conduit à
supprimer ou à réduire des impôts locaux
je dois dire que l'État a supprimé des
impôts locaux il a supprimé ses propres
impôts de cas la TVA
société ABC liée a baissé mais c'est
vrai que les forces est beaucoup porté
au cours des années passées sur sur les
impôts locaux c'est peut-être plus
facile de baisser les impôts des autres
que que les siens mais du coup on
aboutit à un système où finalement
l'impôt local je dirais pas qu'il est
résiduel il joue encore beaucoup mais il
est il est relativement restreint
aujourd'hui et que du coup la logique de
la proposition c'était dire
puisqu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'impôts
locaux autant le concentrer sur le bloc
communal alors ça nous a fait des normes
ennemis avec les départements nous
verrons la semaine prochaine ils sont
pas contents du tout mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'est dit que dans la situation
qui était celle d'aujourd'hui
il va mieux concentrer sur le blocage on
s'est posé sérieusement sans totalement
beauté en touche la question d'un impôts
résidentiel en touche est une manière
d'avancer aussi donc on l'a fait avec
plaisir
objectivement
je comprends bien qu'on porte ce projet
comme étant un projet de d'autonomie
fiscale de rôle des collectivités
locales je pense que c'est que même
difficile à mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui
revenir sur la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation on crée un impôts
résidentiel moi je je suis prêt à saluer
celui qui nous mettra en place je pense
quand même que c'est pas facile et que
du coup en plus on assimilé différentes
hypothèses soit vous faites un impôt
pour tout le monde vous avez un problème
avec les les ménages modestes soit vous
le créez que
le département région et ayons un des
impôts locaux nationaux partagés qui
ressemble un peu aux compétences
économiques ou sociales des
collectivités en cause c'est pour ça
qu'on propose de mettre de la de
partager un peu d's pour les les régions
en disant c'est quand même un peu lié à
leur situation économique à leur rôle
économique en essayant territorialiser
au maximum c'est pas très simple c'est
pas possible pour la TVA c'est prenant
plus l'avantage possible sur l'IS en
prenant en compte des notions qui sont
pas forcément celles de l'impôt lui-même
mais la création d'entreprise la
création pareil pour le les départements
on s'est dit si on peut partager un peu
d'impôts sur le revenu c'est
probablement pas forcément absurde par
rapport au rôle social des des
départements sur l'intercommunalité j'ai
bien entendu jusqu'à ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Duron en jeu on voit bien que
les débats sont très très lourds
certains communautés bon la cour d'une
manière générale la plus tôt était en
faveur de l'intercommunalité et le
dernier rapport qu'elle a sorti des
finances publiques locales et plutôt un
appui à l'intercommunalité donc voilà je
suis pas très étonné de des réactions on
considère plutôt que si les
intercommunalités peuvent jouer un rôle
plus important en matière de répartition
des ressources c'est pas forcément
absurde mais j'entends parfaitement le
risque de l'élu local je suis moi-même
non pas le cas mais à partir d'une toute
petite commune en Lozère je vois très
bien ce que ça peut être le sentiment de
dépossession de l'autonomie des
collectivités locales les plus les plus
petites sur le le sujet des niveaux de
charge je crois que c'est c'est Monsieur
eblet qu'il a évoqué ou un autre des
parlementaires
ce que nous disons dans le rapport c'est
qu'il faut que on s'attache à répartir
soit les impôts nationaux soit les
impôts soit les dotations en prenant 4
on compte non pas la charge effective
que supporte une collectivité
qui serait sa charge objective comme on
l'a fait dans le passé avec des critères
qui sont liés au nom d'habitants à la
composition de la population au nombre
de routes etc donc que ça soit mieux
mieux pris en compte il y a un point qui
a été évoqué qui est DMTO qui est un
sujet extrêmement sensible bon je serai
pas la première fois que que le sujet de
la nationalisation de la rue répartition
des métaux et sur la table je crois que
la Commission de bus Richard auquel
j'avais appartenu il avait évoqué de
manière très très claire sans conclure
en ce sens là
objectivement c'est un impôt tellement
fluctuant ces dernières années c'est
formidable DMTO je suis pas certain que
ça soit dans les deux ou trois années
qui viennent donc voilà je pense qu'il
vaut mieux laisser l'état supporter les
aléas de la conjoncture et et donner aux
collectivités locales des ressources
plus stables voilà mais ensuite je suis
d'accord monsieur monsieur Bretaud c'est
bien une renation pour une rerépartition
voilà on assume clairement la position
est plutôt est plutôt celle là et je
vous dis le département nous en veulent
beaucoup sur l'emprunt qui a été évoqué
aussi c'est vrai qu'on a travaillé sur
la base des ressources actuelles avec un
niveau d'emprunt qui compte pour cette
7% je crois des ressources des
collectivités je crois que le fait que
les emprunt soit faible aujourd'hui
contraste très fortement à ce qui était
il y a une trentaine d'années où
l'emprunt était beaucoup plus important
et qu'il la charge emprunt peut
effortement ce que tu te calmes donc je
crois qu'on est arrivé un système
relativement sain et donc même si
l'emprunt peut être mobilisé pour
l'investissement il faut que ça reste
une une ressource quand même limitée
voilà sur l'essentiel des points qui ont
été évoqués il y a d'autres sur lesquels
je confesse ma mon absence de
compétences sur le demande des taxes
d'aménagement ça je c'est pas dans le
rapport je terminerai sur la question du
mille-feuille oui bien sûr que c'est un
sujet qui est
indissablement lié à la question de des
finances locales en même temps il y a
quatre niveaux de de collectivités
aujourd'hui avec les PCI qui ont un rôle
particulier
il y a une période où le gouvernement
les gouvernements étaient dit faisons
disparaître progressivement les
départements au profit des régions et
puis des intercommunalités et puis les
communes sont le premier niveau
la création des grandes régions qui n'a
pas été porteuse d'économiste je le
confirme
en fait revitalisé considérablement le
département et que avec des régions
aussi grandes que la nouvelle Aquitaine
ou l'Occitanie le grand est aussi je
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué de faire
disparaître les départements donc je
crois que nous sommes assez durablement
dans une logique avec quatre niveaux de
collectivité ensuite mieux vaut répartir
les ressources entre elles de manière la
plus équitable possible et en fonction
de leur de leur compétences
merci monsieur le Président pour cette
synthèse je vais redonner la parole à
chacun des quatre mais je vais vous dire
c'est très simple c'est un exercice très
simple je vais vous demander deux choses
d'abord de tenir un une minute ce qui
veut dire qu'on repart pas sur
l'ensemble et donc de retenir l'idée
principale si je puis dire que vous
retenez de cette phase
d'aujourd'hui et de votre point
d'attention
prioritaire
deuxième sujet dans votre commentaire
comment percevez-vous alors vous l'avez
dit en entrée mais il y a aussi des
formes de politesse je connais on
connais ça dans les échanges courtois
que nous avons les uns avec les autres
mais de votre point de vue y a-t-il
aujourd'hui dans le rapport tel qu'il
est présenté avec toutes les réserves
que vous avez faites une base pour
pouvoir avancer et j'aimerais avoir se
positionnement là-dessus sur
pouvons-nous selon vous avancer sur
cette base sachant que évidemment il
faut tenir compte des remarques des uns
et des autres et éventuellement des
lignes rouges que vous pouvez les uns et
les autres indiquer justement dans votre
retour alors je vais vous proposer de le
refaire à l'envers en donnant la parole
à Sébastien Miossec en premier et puis
on va repartir d'un nid durant ce retour
et et donc vous voyez que j'avais raison
au départ François rebsamin était
astucieux puisqu'il avait indiqué partir
en cours de réunion et que donc il est
toujours là et nous le nous nous le
remercions bien entendu et donc il avait
fait j'avais bien j'avais bien pointé
cette capacité à se situer Sébastien
en une minute donc oui merci
forcément très court
[Musique]
il y a plein de choses très
intéressantes quand élite je retiens
notamment le fait qu'évidemment pour
refonder tout ça à une enveloppe en
pouvoir se partager un gâteau plus grand
ce serait évidemment indispensable
l'inflation d'une certaine façon peut
être un atout dans ce sens-là mais ça
veut dire potentiellement une perte de
pouvoir d'agir pour ceux qui resteraient
à ressources à ressources équivalente je
voudrais juste du coup en conclusion
partager ton optimisme Claude que tu as
dit en tout début de séance
en effet je pense qu'on peut vraiment
envisager une vraie réforme faut pas
qu'on qu'on se dise que le système à
bout de souffle dont on a tous convenu
finalement si on commence à y toucher on
va casser le on va casser le le jouet
entre guillemets donc il faut vraiment
voilà par optimisme mais par confiance
engager ses réformes le rapport pour ce
qui nous concerne et une bonne base
[Musique]
qui pose pas mal de beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes même si évidemment il
faut concerter et puis pour conclure
vraiment la
concurrence entre nous entre les
différents niveaux de collectivités
locales et mortifère donc faut vraiment
qu'on trouve une façon de d'avancer
ensemble je suis mère avant d'être
président d'intercommunalité je suis
parfaitement conscient que le maire et
d'abord la porte d'entrée de beaucoup de
nos concitoyens mais le maire seul il
est souvent désarmé aussi pour faire
plein de choses donc on a besoin d'une
intercommunalité respectueuse et commune
mais qui permet de d'avancer de faire
plein de choses que tout seul on ne peut
pas faire en complémentarité avec le
département et les régions dans leur
responsabilités respectives voilà une
minute 40 désolé d'être un autre long
merci Sébastien Denis
oui une intercommunauté respectueuse et
commune ce qui n'est pas été le cas de
la loi de l'autre qui a créé des gros
intercommunalités qui ont finalement
pénalisé beaucoup de communes surtout
les petites et finalement ça renforcé
l'épaule à l'intérieur donc c'est pour
ça que s'il y a une ligne rouge
pour nous c'est que c'est pas possible
de donner la DGF aux interco pour la
répartir parce que c'est une nouvelle
tutelle qu'on va essayer de créer
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure il y a une des
intervenantes qui a parlé du SPIC si le
SPIC marche alors que la base du SPIC
c'est on donne quand on est au-dessus de
d'un potentiel financier par habitant et
on reçoit quand on est en dessous
malheureusement avec l'échelle
logarithmique les agglo qui sont
au-dessus
reçoivent et des communautés communes
qui sont en dessous donne et il faudrait
supprimer cette échelle logarithmique
qui me semble
vraiment anti républicaine sinon le
principe du flic était bon moi je serais
même pour qu'il y ait deux flics ce qui
résoudrait pas mal la situation c'est de
dire un flic entre communauté de
communes et entre commune on irait vers
plus de solidarité et effectivement moi
je pense que il faut d'aperéquation mais
d'abord
supprimer les les tout ce qui est
antipérique water voilà donc corriger la
DGF et le
je pense que je suis épuisé mon temps de
parole
tout va bien tout va bien voilà ce qui
me paraît important merci merci beaucoup
pierre Breteau
oui en une minute je vais essayer de la
dire de temps je devrais déjà être vous
avoir quitter finalement je suis
beaucoup moins habile que François et je
le savais
tenir quelques propos d'abord
premièrement par rapport à ce qu'il est
dit
la territorialisation de l'impôt local
et du bloc communal et dans ce point de
vue là
sans constant on va dire le rapport va
dans le bon sens qui a été il est bien
sur le bloc communal l'essentiel de
l'impôt local c'est l'assiette qui pose
problème et qui nous donne point de vue
doit être le deuxième point c'est que et
l'inflation
presque une opportunité de ce point de
vue c'est que il faut du grain à moudre
comme vous ça a été dit dans les dans
les débats et c'est que de fait le
système fiscal dotation ne serait
réforme pas enveloppe constante ou sera
la réforme sera extrêmement complexe qui
pose troisième question de mon point de
vue d'être innovant sur la gouvernance
et le pilotage des finances publiques
locales
n'appartient pas de dire dans quel cas
j'entendu tout à l'heure vos collègues
le Sénat ça suppose
mais je pense que la marche est au moins
aussi haute que de réformer
sans son dynamique des bases et puis je
reviens sur je redis parce que je pense
que j'ai entendu ça m'inquiété je serais
ravi d'en reparler
à ça donc d'observation sur l'autonomie
fiscale
mais
la question n'est pas de savoir si les
élus locaux affichent ou pas l'usage la
question est de savoir s'ils peuvent
l'utiliser je vous invite à refaire le
constat
j'ai un collègue dans un an parce que de
fait la question n'est pas de savoir si
la question de savoir si on peut
l'utiliser
si on l'utilise en permanence la
question de savoir si on peut l'utiliser
et je peux vous dire en tout cas dans
mon département cette année qu'un
certain nombre d'élus parce qu'ils
veulent assumer en partie des choix
politiques vont l'activer et il n'avait
pas activé depuis 6 7 10 12 ans c'est le
fait de pouvoir l'utiliser et non pas de
l'utiliser qui compte et de ce point de
vue l'autonomie fiscale c'est un point
essentiel sur la capacité à donner des
marges de manœuvre mais surtout sur la
capacité à décider de la trajectoire
merci de cette précision pierre breton
et nous terminons donc par Françoise
merci merci mes chers collègues élus au
niveau communal
intercommunal je voudrais terminer par
une réflexion très courte et très
globale je voudrais dire que
dans une république qui se dit
décentralisée
parce que cela figure de notre
Constitution cela a été voté l'État
jacobin aujourd'hui continue d'imposer
ses lois ses règles à un bloc communal
qui a à faire face à de plus en plus de
besoins de sa population ses besoins et
se résument à des choses essentielles la
cohésion sociale et on en a tous besoin
et la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique qui est devant nous on en a
pas parlé ce matin derrière tout ça les
propositions moi je trouve
budgétaire qui ont été faites par la
commission et par le rapport sont de
bonnes proposition je souhaite qu'on
n'oublie pas que c'est au niveau
communal qu'on résout les problèmes et
nous allons avoir à de grands problèmes
à résoudre donc renforçant le bloc
communal intercommunal bien évidemment
et juste à notre collègue pour dire que
les intercommunalités
ça fait 20 ans qu'on y travaille elles
sont en place maintenant sur l'ensemble
du territoire certaines se sont faites
de manière défensive sans projet mais
moi je préfère les intercommunalités de
projet et je crois que c'est ce que nous
cherchons tous merci
merci François merci à vous tous pour la
qualité de vos interventions merci chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
merci Madame la rapporteur pour le
travail effectué nous allons donc
poursuivre avec Christian Charpy et
Madame la rapporteur sur une autre
réunion qui sera la semaine prochaine je
le rappelle à mes collègues où nous
aurons une discussion avec les
départements et les régionales et les
régions comment dire qui risque d'être
un tout petit peu plus frictionnelle on
va le dire comme ça mais nous verrons
bien après tout n’anticipons pas
n'anticipons pas je je rappelle
évidemment
au 4 institutions que nous avons invité
quatre associations d'élus que elles ont
la possibilité de compléter cette
audition par un écrit si elle le
souhaite pour venir
repréciser si elle le souhaite leur
position de manière officielle si je
peux me permettre voilà merci à